in this video we're going to study
something called the demographic
transition model which is something
demographers use the demographers are
people who study the makeup of
populations and how those transition
over time and why that might happen and
this model in particular is one to think
about how a country goes from being
pre-industrial to post-industrial and
what happens to the birth rate the death
rate and the total population over time
as they make that transition and as
we'll see it happens over four stages so
let's just first understand what's going
on in this graphic here so our
horizontal axis we see is our time axis
and depending on the country we're
studying this might occur oh in fact
it's definitely going to occur over many
decades but some countries still haven't
even gotten through all of these phases
so it might have been a century already
and they might still be in say this
second phase which we'll describe in a
little bit more detail
the vertical axis you can see it says
rates per thousand and this is useful
for looking at the birth rate and the
death rate the total population here
which is in this light blue color that
really shouldn't be read as a rate that
is the total population you could
probably add another axis here to
measure total population but it's
telling us indicatively where the total
population is
now we see the birth rate in this blue
color and we see the death rate in the
salmon or this pink orange red color
and we can see that as a country is i
guess you could say starting out or
really according to this model we would
call it
pre-industrial phase
which is pre-industrial which is this
phase
right over here you have relatively high
birth rates and relatively high death
rates
why is that happening well in most
pre-industrial societies you have a high
death rate because health care is either
non-existent or it isn't that good so
you could have high child mortality a
lot of people are dying from diseases
that are easy to cure in an industrial
society or in a post-industrial society
which we'll talk about and why is there
a high birth rate
oftentimes culturally women still
haven't entered the workforce in a major
way education generally is at a low
level especially for women at this stage
because fundamentally of a lack of a
health care system for most people you
might not have things like family
planning and so you could imagine that
might lead to an overall higher birth
rate now because both the birth rate and
the death rate are high but they're
about the same you can see that you have
a relatively stable but we'll say in
absolute terms low population
and then countries might start to
industrialize and so we call this state
right here the transitional
state
and we can see that at least on this
graphic it is elongated and different
countries go through this in different
amounts of time you might have a country
like japan that went through this in
less than half a century but you might
have other countries that are still
going through this even after a half a
century or even a century or more but in
the transitional state this country will
start to
industrialize and this whole model is
based on looking at what happened in
europe in the 19th century as much of
europe industrialized and say okay maybe
other countries will go through the same
pattern of demographics as they
industrialize
so let's think about what is happening
here we see that the death rate is
starting to come down pretty reasonably
now the argument why that would happen
as this country is industrializing is
because they would now have better
health care they might have better
nutrition now in fact that's another
reason why the pre-industrial society
might have a high death rate people are
even having illnesses or dying from
malnutrition but now because say farm
productivity is higher because they're
able to use more modern methods the
nutrition is better death rates start
coming down
and birth rates might start coming down
a little bit but not as quickly as the
death rates now why the birth rates
might coming might start coming down
well once again access to health care
more women might be able to enter the
workforce you're having a higher level
of education as the society starts to
develop and becomes wealthier
now with the death rate going down at a
faster rate than the birth rate all of a
sudden this will add to the population
if fewer people are dying than being
born the population is increasing over
time and in fact the rate of population
increase is increasing as this gap
between birth rate and death rate
increases
now the next stage of our demographic
transition model we would consider
industrial
and
the real marker of that
is we see that in the industrial phase
our birth rate is starting to catch up
with our death rate and so this phase
women might be entering in the workforce
in a major way culturally it is far more
acceptable for things like family
planning culturally far more acceptable
for people to delay giving birth
especially for women so that they could
get their education
and there's just more awareness that by
having fewer children the children you
do have will be more prosperous will get
better nutrition the family is overall
likely to be wealthier so as the birth
rate and the death rate curve get closer
and closer together the rate of
population growth starts to slow
and then this last phase right here over
here the fourth phase in our demographic
transition model which we could call
post
industrial
we see that not only has the birth rate
caught up to the death rate that it
actually can go below the death rate and
so in that situation you have a stable
population but if the birth rate
actually even goes below the death rate
you can all you can even see the
population begin to decline and there
are societies that are already there for
example japan has a declining population
even places like the united states if we
did not have immigration you would have
a declining population because we are in
this last phase right over here and this
post-industrial declining population
because birth rates have gotten so low
have its own set of issues
you now have an aging population if
birth rates are much lower and people
are living much longer a higher and
higher percentage of the population is
older older people especially once they
are out of the workforce who's going to
support them who is going to provide the
health care for them where are those
resources going to come from
if your population is shrinking then
your economy might not be growing as
fast which would make it even harder to
support the cost of an aging population
so i'll leave you there once again this
is a model it's a hypothesis but it's a
useful one to at least have a framework
of how things might transition into
society over time and people use this
type of model to advise countries
especially ones that might be in this
transitional state and the transitional
state sometimes the place where
countries might get stuck because
they're getting delayed economic
development so they're not quite able to
get to industrial and so demographers
economists others will think about well
how can you make this transition as well
as possible